Transcription: Coline BUGNOT
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour, je m’appelle Christophe Haag,
je suis écrivain,
professeur-chercheur à l’EMLYON
et je m’intéresse
aux émotions, aux intuitions
et au concept d’intelligence émotionnelle.
On va tout de suite rentrer
dans le vif du sujet.
Vous le savez, ce n'est pas grâce à notre
force physique que nous sommes arrivés
tout en haut de la pyramide des espèces.
On n’a ni les incisives d’un T.Rex,
ni la force musculaire d’un ours.
Ce qui fait notre différence,
notre force,
ce sont nos émotions et plus
précisément notre liant émotionnel.
Tout ce qui nous lie les uns aux autres.
C’est ce qui vient nourrir
les synergies collectives.
Vous prenez l’astrophysicien
le plus intelligent au monde,
celui avec la mécanique intellectuelle
la mieux huilée,
seul, il n’arrive pas à envoyer
quelqu’un sur la Lune.
Elon Musk, seul, n’arrive pas à créer
Tesla, Space X
ou, dans un futur proche,
un Jurassic Park.
Ce qui vient nourrir ces synergies,
ce sont les émotions,
et plus précisément la libre
circulation de ces émotions
d’un individu à l’autre,
d’un esprit à l’autre,
d’un corps à l’autre.
Cette libre circulation,
elle est essentielle.
Elle est essentielle pour avancer,
elle est essentielle pour créer
ensemble tout un tas d’éléments.
Vous savez, l'émotion, c'est ce qui vient
déclencher des mécaniques d'empathie,
d’amitié, d’amour, de passion qui nous
permettent de mieux nous adapter,
et notamment de mieux nous adapter à cette
crise que nous traversons tous,
qui est autant une crise sanitaire,
économique qu’une crise psychologique.
Sans l’émotion,
sans cette particule de Dieu
comme je l’appelle,
nous ne serions pas grand-chose.
L’émotion,
on sait la mesurer, sa durée,
son intensité, son impact psychologique,
son impact physique sur notre santé.
On sait même parcourir le chemin
qu’elle trace dans le cerveau
grâce à tout un tas d’outils sophistiqués.
Aujourd’hui, sans elle,
sans cette particule de Dieu,
nous ne serions que des pantins sans âme.
Des Pinocchio sans magie.
Il y a un peu plus d’un an,
malheureusement,
il y a un petit bout de tissu
qui s’est invité dans notre quotidien.
Ce petit bout de tissu,
il est venu contraindre la libre
circulation de l’émotion.
Cet objet, celui-ci, c’est le masque.
On le connaît tous.
Il vient tout simplement supprimer tout un
tas d'expressions sur le visage humain
qui sont synonymes d'expressions
émotionnelles.
Il vient gommer les activités des grands
zygomatiques, synonymes de joie.
Il vient masquer des joues rougies
par un amour naissant.
Tout ça, c’est problématique
parce qu’en empêchant
l’émotion de s’exprimer librement,
on empêche la contagion
émotionnelle d’opérer.
Et la contagion émotionnelle,
c’est un phénomène extraordinaire.
C’est quelque chose qui se produit
très rapidement,
dès que nous interagissons avec quelqu’un.
Chaque fois que je te parle, chaque fois
que je te regarde, je vais t’imiter.
En t’imitant, je vais ressentir
ce que tu ressens.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Et quand je dis très rapide,
c’est vraiment très rapide.
Il suffit de 21 millièmes de seconde
pour enclencher ce processus
d’imitation inconsciente.
C'est le temps de projection
d'une image au cinéma.
C’est dix fois plus rapide que le temps
qu’il fallait à Mohamed Ali
pour repérer un signal lumineux et réagir
à ce signal lumineux par un uppercut.
Le masque vient donc contraindre
cette contagion-là.
Et ça, c’est problématique et ça pourrait
fragiliser totalement notre position
en tant qu’espèce dominante et
nous faire dégringoler de la pyramide.
Sans synergie,
on n’est pas grand-chose.
On le voit bien avec le masque, aussi,
le rapport à l’autre
est devenu métallique,
robotique, sans saveur.
Il nous empêche de repérer les
objections, les approbations,
les incompréhensions, les intentions,
les pensées de l’autre.
Et tout ça est très compliqué pour nous.
Et tout ça vient court-circuiter
la nature des choses.
Pour pouvoir remédier à ça,
dites-vous qu’il y a quelque chose
de fondamental à retenir.
C’est que l’émotion, comme la vie,
trouve toujours un chemin.
Grâce à notre propre nature,
on s’adapte à tout, y compris au masque.
Et moi, ce qui m’intéresse ici, c’est de
vous montrer toutes ces possibilités
de toujours continuer à emprunter
les couloirs émotionnels
qui nous maintiennent
en contact avec l’autre.
Souvenez-vous de cette citation du
Docteur Ian Malcom dans « Jurassic Park »
qui est la suivante
et que je vais vous lire.
« Il y a une chose que l’histoire
de l’évolution nous a apprise,
c’est que la vie
ne peut pas être contenue,
la vie prend le large.
La vie conquiert de nouveaux territoires,
elle renverse toutes les barrières.
C’est parfois pénible,
c’est parfois dangereux
mais enfin, c’est comme ça. »
L’émotion, comme la vie,
ne peut être contenue.
Fermez-lui la porte,
elle va passer par la fenêtre.
C’est de toutes ces fenêtres-là
dont je veux parler aujourd’hui,
tous ces couloirs émotionnels
qui sont possibles.
On va commencer par un de ces couloirs
qui est d’une puissance
émotionnelle extraordinaire.
C’est la voix.
La voix, c’est un peu un second visage,
elle est extrêmement expressive.
À travers la voix, on peut faire passer
tout un tas d’émotions de base
comme la joie, la tristesse,
la colère, etc.,
par des modifications dans l’intonation,
dans le débit de parole, dans les pauses,
dans les fréquences fondamentales, etc.
Pour illustrer ce pouvoir absolu
de la voix,
je vous emmène à la rencontre
de Christophe Caupenne.
Christophe Caupenne, c’est quelqu’un que
j’ai rencontré il y a quelque temps
et il a été pendant douze ans à la tête de
la cellule négociation du RAID.
Et son surnom là-bas, c’était « la Voix ».
Ce qui est assez fou, c’est qu’on est
allés faire un bilan phoniatrique,
donc une analyse de la voix
de Christophe Caupenne.
Ce qu’on a repéré,
c’est que sa voix est médium, bien posée,
avec un fluide qui est très bon.
Elle est rassurante, apaisante.
Chaque fois qu’il parle,
Caupenne induit des sensations plaisantes
chez les écoutants
Dans chaque situation extrême,
Caupenne va jouer avec sa voix.
Pour faire quoi ?
Pour entrer en fréquence d’intimité avec
les preneurs d’otages, les terroristes
ou autres forcenés.
Comme ce jour
où il s’est retrouvé à négocier
avec un forcené
qui tenait en joue sa femme
et qui menaçait de la tuer
et de se tuer lui-même après.
Cette personne venait
de la région bordelaise et avait un accent
de ce coin de France très prononcé.
Or, il se trouve que Caupenne lui-même
est d’origine bordelaise
et au moment d’interagir avec ce forcené
à l’autre bout du fil,
cet accent est réapparu.
En se rapprochant
acoustiquement, vocalement,
ces deux personnages se sont également
rapprochés émotionnellement.
De l'empathie est apparue entre les deux.
La distance sociale, poum,
s’est carrément réduite
et derrière, tout ça a eu un impact
émotionnel fort chez le forcené.
Cette personne qui était
en tension extrême,
qui voulait en découdre
avec les forces de l’ordre,
tout à coup,
rien qu’au son de la voix de Caupenne,
est descendue en tension.
Sa colère, sa rage même, s’est peu à peu
évaporée, laissant place à de la sérénité.
Autre exemple de la puissance de la voix.
Cette fois-ci, je ne suis pas allé
investiguer des gentils mais des méchants.
Avec une médecin phoniatre qui s’appelle
Elisabeth Fresnel, une médecin de la voix,
nous avons observé les voix
de plusieurs gourous,
dont Luc Jouret, qui est le cofondateur
de la tristement célèbre
secte de l’Ordre du Temple solaire,
la secte la plus meurtrière en France.
Et ce qu’on voulait faire,
c’était comprendre
comment ces gens arrivaient à hameçonner
émotionnellement leurs victimes.
Et les résultats sont assez surprenants.
Il se trouve que les gourous
ont en commun une chose :
c’est qu’ils ont une voix supra chiante,
avec très, très peu
de variations mélodiques,
très peu de variations
dans les hauteurs tonales,
bref des voix très monotones.
Ce qui est surprenant,
c’est qu’on attribue souvent à ces gens-là
un certain esthétisme dans la voix,
celle de très, très bons communicants.
Eux préfèrent choisir des voix discrètes
parce que ça leur donne un air calme,
rassurant, faussement rassurant.
C’est un peu la même voix que celle des
hypnotiseurs qui arrivent à induire
des émotions, des suggestions
dans l’esprit de leurs patients.
Donc la voix, vous l’avez compris,
peut bypasser le masque
et peut permettre cette connexion
émotionnelle entre les individus.
Autre couloir émotionnel
que l’on peut emprunter
et auquel il faut être encore plus
attentif aujourd’hui, c’est le regard.
Les émotions passent à travers le regard,
notamment les émotions authentiques
comme la joie qui va activer les muscles
orbiculaires, ceux autour des yeux,
et qui vont enfin
vous permettre de déceler,
quand vous allez produire une blague
un peu pourrie,
si la personne rit sincèrement ou pas
à cette blague pourrie.
La tristesse, la gratitude peuvent
également passer à travers le regard.
L’amour, tiens, parlons un peu de l’amour.
Placez deux personnes amoureuses
l’une en face de l’autre,
et là, il va se produire quelque chose.
Leurs pupilles vont se dilater
et leur rythme cardiaque et leur rythme
respiratoire vont se synchroniser.
Vous avez une région de leur cerveau,
une zone du cerveau
qui va également s’illuminer.
C’est le striatum ventral qui est
une zone directement impliquée
dans les mécanismes de récompense.
Vous allez également avoir une vague
de neurotransmetteurs et d’hormones
qui va être libérée.
Bref, le masque n’arrive pas
à contenir l’amour.
Y compris l’amour entre une maman
et son enfant,
entre une femme enceinte et son fœtus.
Là, j’ai envie de vous parler
de contagion maternelle.
Pour vous expliquer ce phénomène,
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître,
je vais vous amener dans l’espace.
On est en 1992,
Michel Tognini, un astronaute français, va
rejoindre la station Mir pour y effectuer,
14 jours durant,
tout un tas d’expériences scientifiques.
Michel Tognini m’a écrit
une très belle lettre
que j’ai publiée dans mon dernier bouquin
et dont je vous livre un extrait.
«Je flotte en apesanteur.
La sensation s’apparente à celle
que nous éprouvons lorsque nous sommes
en plongée sous-marine
avec le corps
parfaitement lesté et équilibré.
C’est une sensation agréable et qui
semble naturelle rapidement...
C’est un rappel d’une condition
qu’on a connue auparavant.
Je crois vraiment, pour aller
encore plus loin dans mon propos,
que la vie psychique
et émotionnelle du spationaute
s’apparente à celle du fœtus.
Je me sentais dans la station Mir
comme dans le ventre de ma mère,
protégé et serein. »
Le parallèle entre ce qu’écrit
si poétiquement Michel Tognini
et la vraie vie émotionnelle
du fœtus est flagrant.
On sait aujourd’hui qu’une maman
qui expérimente des émotions
va les transmettre directement
à son petit locataire intra-utérin.
Si la maman est bien dans ses baskets,
elle va produire des hormones
directement liées à cet état de bien-être.
Si elle est stressée,
elle va transmettre son stress
parce que le fœtus est très
perméable à ce stress.
Et la barrière, la frontière placentaire
est extrêmement poreuse.
Ce qui est encore plus fou,
c’est qu’on sait aujourd’hui
qu’une maman peut transmettre,
notamment son stress,
bien avant de tomber enceinte.
C’est les résultats d’une étude
parue dans «Nature» en 2018
et qui portait sur 14 espèces
de vertébrés, dont Homo sapiens.
Les auteurs de cette étude
laissent entendre
que si la maman a subi
un traumatisme dans son passé
ou un stress chronique
quelque temps avant la conception,
elle donnera naissance
à un enfant stressé.
Il va y avoir une surexpression
au niveau d’un gène directement impliqué
dans la sécrétion d’hormones,
au niveau notamment
du lobe frontal et des ovules,
et qu’on retrouvera chez l’enfant.
Alors, je ne suis pas là
pour culpabiliser les mamans,
les papas eux aussi peuvent
contaminer leur progéniture.
Vous avez tout un tas
d’études qui montrent que,
probablement à travers des modifications
du génome des spermatozoïdes,
les papas peuvent transmettre
leur stress à leurs enfants
et ce, sur deux ou trois générations.
On peut aussi se dire que
la contagion émotionnelle
peut être positive et donc bénéfique.
Enfin, rien n’est irréversible.
Grâce à l’épigénétique,
grâce aux expériences de vie,
les cartes peuvent être rebattues,
tout simplement.
Allez, je vais maintenant conclure
avec un message pour vous tous.
On le voit,
le masque ne tue pas les émotions.
Le masque, finalement,
n’est qu’une difficulté
dans l’interaction avec l’autre,
mais ce n’est pas
un rempart infranchissable.
Utilisez tous ces couloirs émotionnels
dont je vous parle, ils sont importants,
ils sont vitaux pour nous,
car souvenez-vous,
c’est ce qui fait notre force.
Là il y a une question importante,
c’est la nature des émotions
qu’on doit transmettre aux autres
et que je n’ai pas encore
abordée jusqu’à présent.
C’est bien de les transmettre,
mais quel type d’émotions tu transmets ?
Quel type d’agent pathogène
as-tu envie d’être ?
As-tu envie d’émettre des émotions
bénéfiques ou des émotions toxiques
pour toi et pour les autres ?
Là, il faut choisir son camp.
Vous savez, depuis quelques années,
j’étudie, j’investigue, j’enquête
sur une partie de la population,
une espèce bien particulière
qui se reproduit aussi vite que les lapins
dans la verte prairie écossaise
et que j’ai appelée les enflures toxiques.
Dans enflures toxiques
il y a « enflé », amplifié.
Ces personnes produisent constamment
des émotions nocives, néfastes,
qui sont malaisantes,
qui placent l’autre en situation
d’inconfort, d’infériorité, d’insécurité
et qui viennent donc impacter
la santé psychique et physique
de la personne qui attrape
ces émotions-là.
Moi, je vous invite à ne pas jouer
dans ce registre.
Alors certes, on est tous l'enflure
toxique de quelqu'un.
Après, il y a des degrés.
Moi, j’en connais des certifiées
qui ont fait de
l’enflurie toxique un métier
comme des politiques ont fait
de la politique un métier.
Ne tombez pas dans ce registre-là
parce que ces personnes,
arrivées à un certain âge,
regardent dans le rétroviseur de leur vie
et là elles sont submergées
de remords et de regrets.
Ceux d’avoir mal agi dans sa vie,
d’avoir eu un taux d’émission
d’émotions toxiques
supérieur à la moyenne,
d’avoir fait du mal autour d’elles,
et quand elles prennent conscience de ça,
elles se prennent
une réelle claque psychique.
Et beaucoup d’entre elles tombent malades,
tombent en dépression, en burn out
et vous les voyez ensuite déambuler
dans les couloirs de cliniques privées
comme des zombies totalement médicamentés.
Quand vous voyez ça,
ça fait extrêmement mal.
Donc, essayez derrière de produire
des émotions bénéfiques.
C’est ce que disait Desmund Tutu, le prix
Nobel, un des prix Nobel que je préfère :
«Faites le bien par petits bouts,
là où vous êtes ;
car ce sont tous ces petits bouts de bien,
une fois assemblés
qui transforment le monde. »
Appelez ça comme vous voulez.
Effet papillon, théorie du chaos.
On fait partie d’un tout émotionnel
et on fait partie de cette mer vibratoire
dans laquelle on nage
et chacun de nos mouvements,
de nos expressions,
de nos productions comportementales
peuvent créer des petites ondes
qui peuvent se transformer
en vaguelettes, en vagues, en tsunami
et qui peuvent modifier
tout le système entier
et renverser ce que j’appelle moi
le hum émotionnel négatif,
c’est-à-dire un trop-plein de négativité.
C’est un bourdonnement
sourd, psychique, émotionnel
que les chercheurs
en psychologie sociale comme moi
entendons depuis quelques années
et qui peut faire que
l’humanité vrille d’un coup d’un seul.
A trop baigner dans la négativité,
à un moment on peut devenir fou.
Donc, pour conclure, j’ai envie de vous
dire que c’est intéressant
et c’est important de se focaliser
sur l’empreinte carbone, le CO2,
les petits oiseaux, etc.
Mais c’est aussi important de s’intéresser
à sa propre empreinte émotionnelle.
Quelle trace émotionnelle vais-je
laisser derrière moi ?
De mon passage sur Terre ?
Ça, c’est quelque chose de fondamental.
Si vous ne voulez pas finir dans une
clinique privée à déambuler comme ça,
trouvez un équilibre émotionnel,
faites du bien autour de vous
et vous allez avoir un retour
sur investissement affectif.
C’est de l’investissement affectif,
c’est bien plus fiable, bien plus solide
que l’investissement dans l’or et
dans l’immobilier, je vous assure.
Cette empreinte émotionnelle
est fondamentale.
C’est la trace ultime
que vous allez laisser
de votre passage sur
cette petite boule bleue.
Et souvenez-vous d’une chose :
on a un CDD de vie
sur cette petite boule bleue.
Qu’est-ce que vous en faites ?
C'est une chance inouïe de pouvoir
exister et coexister.
Ne la gâchez pas.
En vrai de vrai,
l’homme est bon envers l’homme,
on peut voir la situation actuelle,
la crise qu’on traverse
sous un angle différent,
et on peut voir l’acronyme COVID
différemment.
On peut le voir ainsi :
chance offerte
ou chance qui nous est offerte
de valider ou de vivre notre propre ID,
notre vrai ID, notre vraie identité,
celle d’être un agent pathogène bénéfique
pour soi, pour les autres
et pour l’humanité.
Merci à vous.